Latin sentences and sayings seem to be
designed to be carved out of stone this
is a matter of their concision and
weightiness because of its highly
inflected grammatical structure Latin
uses far fewer words to express
something that a non inflected language
such as English here are some of our
favorite Latin sayings
vanie vidi vici Julius Caesar's most
famous remark apparently made in the
Roman Senate in 47 BC and referring to
his victory over King faun a sees the
second of Pontus at the Battle of Zeller
is an example of Latin at its most
concise English takes twice as many
words to convey the same meaning the
English translation doesn't come close
to matching the patent terseness there's
alliterative V's those final long eyes
of the original requiescat in part a one
of the most familiar of all that in
sayings is unusual in not being notably
more terse than the English equivalent
but here the weightiness and solemnity
of Latin come to the fore
the big words have a sort of varrock
splendor and strictly speaking this is
more succinct or conveys more meaning in
the same number of words than the
English equivalent because the Latin
word requiescat is a subjunctive and
represent a pious wish may he or she
rest not a simple command
carpe diem the famous saying from the
eleventh poem of Horace's first book of
ODEs is possibly the best-known Latin
tag of all it's certainly the one which
has inspired the naming of more
restaurants and wine bars than any other
why is it so memorable and why does it
work so well in Latin for a start it has
the classical Latin succinctness just to
balance the syllables to convey a whole
world of meaning even an entire
philosophy in this case the philosophy
of epicureanism there is also the
weightiness especially in the second
world a Latin D s is more significant
than a mere English day and finally this
poet saying has a marvelous poetic
ambiguity and richness
as the word carpe can mean so many
different things from seas to pluck homo
son cumali nil and they Ally ennum Toto
for this saying from the early Roman
comedian Terence is genius for plain
eloquence the English version is 50%
longer in terms of words and nothing
like as memorable especially when it
comes to word order the ability to
manipulate word order is a great
advantage that Latin gains from its
grammatical inflections the way nouns
and adjectives incorporate their own
cases and verbs include person mood and
tense within a single word here being
able to hold back the verb to the end of
the sentence enables parents to
juxtapose the home assume with the
Romani nil parturient Montez Ness
scatter ridiculous muss here from
Horace's ARS Poetica his hugely
influential treatise on how to write is
a lovely example of Latin being playful
as it were using its own weightiness
against itself Latin is able to enact
the process whereby a huge effort the
mountains going into labor produces a
laughably puny result the birth of the
minuscule unimpressive rodent cap acts
in pari
Nissi impure asset the master of the
withering liters put down in Latin or
maybe in all languages is the Roman
historian Tacitus this marvelous
forwarder refers to the emperor Galba
but could be seen as an equally fitting
epitaph on at least one recent British
prime minister here both succeeds
enabled by grammar and the unique Latin
weightiness and a perfect expression
caelum non-animal mutant qui trans Mari
current
another Parisian Jen this time from his
first book of epistles depends once
again for its memorable force on the
genius of Latin grammar the way the
accusative tense is signals in the final
owners of caelum and animam so that the
contrast between the climate or color of
the sky caelum which the traveler can
change and her state of mind animam
which the traveler can't alter so easily
is pointed up with a maximum impact
latin more than any other tongue is the
language in which things are not just
said but stay said the tight grammatical
structure of the language helps give
Latin sayings a massive architectural
grandeur the verbal equivalent of a
Colosseum the pantheon or the pond ooga
like those great edifices they are built
to stand the test of time we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now